après un bon alors vous n'êtes pas en
faire une interview à peine d'haïti qui
les plus grands moments des visiteurs et
plus grand monde hésite à votre grande
joie ensemble fait cet avenir à mon avis
le pire moment
le caire maman davis c'était pour moi ça
a été le concert à bourges
1 c'était grave ac c'est là qu'on s'est
dit c'est pas les bons visiteurs ouais
ouais c'est bourré de visiteurs on sait
pas gouré parce qu'on s'aime on s'aime
quand même on voit toujours les anciens
visiteurs mais on sait comment vous avez
fait alors et bayer il y en a un qui est
parti à ce que casual idée on veut que
tout autant il a dit lui même je crois
que je vais m'en aller et revenus du
canada mais on s'est rendu compte que
c'était pas un grain que ça fonctionnait
pas comme ce qu'on aimait le plus grand
groupe de rock du monde par exemple
c'est quoi c'est qui
où ça se discute à mon avis entre les
stones cd ou aille à ce qu'il conserve
aujourd'hui torontois en qualité
musicale c'est les zep ou new beaters
ans que thé rox et les stones c'est un
côté humour seller vous vrai et le plus
nul je mes enfants et je veux vraiment
une
je suis sûr à j'ai vu un groupe vraiment
nul s'adapter aux smiths the ring ah bon
c'est quoi inventer j'avais dit que
c'est génial là plus l'effort d'y aller
et je tiens à l'elysée montmartre
j'avais beau coup de pub j'avais entendu
beaucoup plus et qu'on dise un peu plus
blast le smi ce ring à beauséjour gras
ouais avec une tendance moderniste et
des sales gueules de la musique
bon alors chez les français maintenant
le meilleur français contre groupe
auchan par laurent michaud que sa part
mis à gratter
j'aime beaucoup la mano negra devenu
c'est dégueulasse on aime bien taper sur
la vie des mets entre nos peuples et qu
il allait mettre un pas je ne m a pas le
niveau des buts